Okay, we are live, I guess.
And uh fix something for the drive
environment. And then we found a puffer
bug. So I got to fix the puffer bug.
Just a puffer bug.
It will fix the render bug
and we will Continue.
Does this run full?
Oh.
I'm being a little lazy here, but I
think we're going to have to do it this
way.
I don't like letting this thing just do
this. That's why I got to be done with
this update. I don't have the capacity
to [ __ ] edit anything anymore at this
point. Um,
but I just let it do. Yeah, this is
fine.
Hey, Jess.
Wait, did the chat just come back on? I
don't know if any of these messages are
new. Um,
I am fixing bugs and refactoring. Crap.
Render's broken. Quick fix though.
Oh yeah. Was it numerically identical?
It was right. Yeah.
I don't know how I could have a bug that
major in the release still. That's just
embarrassing.
How do I Wait, is there a Is there a
reserve thing
I don't want to win the thing. I just
want to reserve it.
needs to be fed, pet, and cleaned up
after.
Okay, I This is kind of dumb. I just
want the [ __ ] holo projector with the
fish.
That's kind of freaking awesome.
I actually like the uh the flat shaded
version of it as like a 2D.
The flat shaded actually looks really
freaking good.
It's a new product. Um, no idea. Razor
head. Yeah, it's a new product.
Obviously, I don't care about the the
stupid AI companion. I just want a
projector with the puffer, you know.
What am I working on? Hey, Jess. Um, it
was just for fixing drive. So, we got a
basic drive integration which is nice.
basic basic drive integration and I
fixed a big bug.
I got to start working on the custom
encoders. I'm getting a headache though,
so I got to just finish a couple
messages I got on the side screen here
and then I'm going to grab an Advil and
then we're going to sit down and we're
going to work on the encoder.
Dude, I don't need blue light glasses. I
can literally do that in the [ __ ]
monitor settings. I literally already
have it on it. Like, it already dims
itself at night.
When am I aiming? Hopefully next week.
down.
And this There's someone else. Where's
the
Um
yeah know that's cuda 12
I thought I had um
Oh, wait. No, I do have 131.
Do 20 million
steps.
10 million steps.
Okay.
Um,
It kind of depends. I'm trying something
real quick, man.
Then fixing bugs on every on like stuff
that does matter in the process. That's
My questions
are not what
I'm confused. Jess
working on. Oh, yeah. There's a lot of
cool stuff
for five, but I'm Jess. I'm like I'm
like on fumes at the moment, which is
weird because it honestly it feels like
I've gotten plenty of rest and it feels
like I should be good and I get up in
the morning, I'm good. But then I just
can't speak in complete sentences. by
halfway through the day. Um,
so I think I just need to take some time
off pretty soon is what it comes down to
so that I can [ __ ] function.
Like I've had some wins with Puffer and
with some other stuff recently, so it
feels like oh, I should be nice and
refreshed. But that's not really a
substitute for just taking some time
just relax.
I'm honestly probably just going to like
take four or five days and just like
play the dumbest possible [ __ ] I can on
Runescape. Just like click click click
click and listen to an audio book.
go through 50 hours of book in a week
and just like sit here
and run. Also run. I do need to run.
That's basically it.
What is Yeah, the problem is it usually
ends up being that a week isn't enough
either, Jess. It usually just ends up
being that I have a lull of like several
weeks between really big blocks of work.
And like I get some stuff done, but the
more time I take off, the shorter it is
that I'm like out.
But I, you know, I need I have
obligations and things I got to do. Any
book wrecks? I've been reading the
Stormlight Archives at the moment. It
has a very very slow start, but it's
kind of good.
What is the puffer doing?
The puffer is puffing
as always. That's what puffers do. They
puff.
having your email in the same room.
That's funny.
I'd believe it. Like just the amount of
like just,
you know, I'm in just like the
everything and everyone just needs to
[ __ ] off and let me just chill for a bit
and then be good. I actually really am
excited about all the new stuff, but I'm
not going to be able to do it for a
while.
These bots sure as hell don't help.
Wish we could just launch some Patriot
missiles at whoever the [ __ ] makes
these.
buffered but live. Yeah, I just ran too
big of a test
for this.
Let me see how this is implemented.
This is like a really basic ass kernel.
Grid size of total columns.
Block size
Atomic add is a software cast loop
vert.
90.
Okay, so it's the same
Hey, muffin.
Where's you going?
nice visualizations? Yeah, we pretty
much got a good draft of the trailer.
I need to insert the constellation video
in the part where it pauses and I got to
insert a puffer fish.
So, this is where the constellation clip
will go.
And then
Yeah, I'm missing. Are you making it for
puffer three or puffer four? Weston
Three,
you added the environment.py, right? The
one line in there for the registration.
You added the name to the any you built
it.
What do you mean you're missing
something? Like what's what's the error?
I don't like the companions thing on
this, but I just I want one of these
stupid little projectors that I can put
the puffer fish in,
you know? I don't want it to be an AI
comp. I just want it to be a little
puffer fish and a hollow projector that
sits on my desk.
Why does everything have to be AI?
Sutton was not right about everything,
my guy.
He's awesome, but he's got
one part of it.
Yeah. So, it's the call to IM kernel
needs to be
for the IM to call kernel here. Yeah.
Needs to be way faster.
Anybody know like basic ass first
optimization? What would you do with
this?
is it just launching way too many
threads.
That's actually pretty [ __ ] good.
That's a good clip.
Speaking of which, I did technically
tell a client that I would be free now
if they happen to reply.
Let's see if I have an email asking me
for late night meeting. I [ __ ] do,
don't I? Nope. Tomorrow. Yay. Good.
Because I am not coherent.
to say if I have a like, yeah, let's
have a meeting now. I'm just going to
[ __ ] explode.
But I try to make sure the clients are
happy.
That's April Fools.
What?
The meeting. No, the meeting's not April
Fools.
dude.
Where are my logs?
build dependencies.
Wait for puffer 4.
What has
shouldn't be installing build
dependencies for 20 minutes.
That's on garbage internet and the
download takes forever.
No for three for scikitle learn. Why the
[ __ ] do we even have scikit learn in
there?
I don't know why that silently fails as
well.
Interesting project. Thank you. We have
very fast puffer
meaning very fast reinforcement learning
demos at puffer.ai.
or coming soon.
Oh, okay. So, there was pre-processing.
I lost it.
So this is just a really dumb porting
error.
Looks like we eval right.
Wait, did
Yeah, you can move.
Is there a reason they're stuck on this
wall?
Seems a little off, doesn't it?
It was starting to learn right at the
end there.
game based reinforcement learning code
I'm familiar with is implemented in
Python. This is yeah so all of our I'm
sorry I missed your messages. So um all
our M's are in C and the training back
end is as of this new release is be
going to be in raw CUDA. It was in like
optimized large batch PyTorch before.
Um, but we really hit the limitations of
what we could do with that. We got that
to training at like 3 to 5 mil steps per
second and we can hit up to 20 million
with this new back end which is pretty
cool.
You're catching me basically in the last
week for before release where I have
zero brain cells left whatsoever.
Um, it's usually not just me typing crap
into Claude.
Okay, the victory stats look good here
now,
updated import. What? Holy. Wait. Why do
I have five messages at once? import
sequence. How come C not C++?
Uh that's not actually convenient, man.
The implementations just suck and you
end up getting perf limited by using
abstractions you don't need. Like most
of the time you go for a hashmap, you
should just be building an index and
doing an array and it's way faster.
Oh, it's O of one. But it's O of one
with a giant ass constant. It's not
actually fast.
C is easy. People think C++ is easier.
It's not. It's not more easy. It's just
more [ __ ]
Okay, this is actually winning some
games with a really stupid policy.
So, that's kind of good.
If I can just like guess decent enough
hyperparameters to do something, we can
solve it on a sweep.
I might even be able to just solve this.
Yeah, I might be able to just solve this
overnight on a sweep.
you'd have to rewrite the thing. So
technically, yes, my work is very
applicable to robotics. It's just not my
top interest area. So we have some
robotics and control stuff, but not a
ton.
Like robotics is maybe third or fourth
among my interests.
Okay, so this is like not terrible,
I think.
[ __ ]
waiter lib ocean sequence.
You don't even have that, dude. That's
not even a thing that exists.
Oh, wait. That's your file
does not define module export function.
Make an underscore_nit file in your
folder, dude. Try that
module. I think that's just straight up.
You need an underscore net file. I don't
know.
Soccer.
What about it?
Doesn't export.
What was the error? My Twitch scrolled
or my like chat scrolled.
I'll see if I can think.
I have precious few brain cells
remaining though, my guy.
You got to love the 1.2 gigs of VRAM
usage out of this thing.
probably will want to redo the space of
Moa.
does not define
module export fun. Did you not build
custom encoders work. Yes, Jess. It's a
pain in the ass, basically.
Okay, here's one for Ocean. There's a
bunch of custom kernels because it uses
a bunch of fancy ops. And then if we
just scroll down
past all the kernels,
what' you do, Weston? All right. So, you
make the weights, you make the
activations, you make the encoder
weights. This is a custom encoder. You
define a forward function, you define a
backward function. Simple [ __ ] The
fancy ass thing is you got to define an
init function for your weights that like
calls like in it on your weights. You
got to call you got to register your
parameter shapes for the encoder and for
training. You're responsible for all
your buffer shapes. This encoder is very
[ __ ] because it has a whole bunch of
parameters which is why this code is
ass. Um,
a lot of it can be much much simpler,
but you're basically just defining
everything and then you register all
your functions to this table here.
It sucks. I know
you don't need them most of the time.
And here's the API. It's right there for
you.
I don't know what else to do about it.
Wrong file and edited the wrong one.
Well, that'll do it, my guy.
multi-line comments. Yeah, the encoder
for Nurmmo is definitely LLM [ __ ] I
though I will tell you the um the
default encoder like the default network
is not the default stuff I've actually
taken the time and made quite good. So,
it's not Bad.
It's really not as complicated that it
look as it looks though. Like based on
the stuff you've done with the chess and
if you just start reading the um
models.cu see you. It's just a neural
net where you actually have to allocate
your own buffers. All the activations,
that [ __ ] has to live somewhere in
memory, right? That's all it [ __ ] is.
All right, cool.
I'm going to hope this works.
I'll call it a day.
We got Moa sleeping.
He's cool.
Life easy for I try, man.
a lot of [ __ ] to handle.
Spencer will be happy about this. It's
one fewer end that we got to freaking
write a custom encoder for.
It's like right here.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
So, if we can get away doing just like
this one and nothing else, that would
rock.
Yeah, we have 20 plus of these easy,
right?
Okay,
I'm calling it for the night, folks. Um,
I'll be on tomorrow morning kind of late
because I got an 11:00 a.m. with a
client.
If you want to support my work,
try the puffer on GitHub. It really
helps me out.
You'd be surprised how much it helps.
Discord if you want to get involved.
Follow X for more stuff. Delete the
numbers.